um for you man like how do you feel
about uh
where because the perception of
being a Mexican in hip-hop I think is
starting to become more like you're an
artist who I look I look at you like
you're an artist who just happens to be
Mexican you know what I'm saying yeah I
mean you're just making a lot of dope
[__] like like
yeah but I'm saying like for you do you
feel that that that like stigma going
away where it's like you know I feel
like oh Jeezy's help with that I feel
like that Mexican OT is helping with
that you're you're doing your thing with
that but like do you feel like you know
now it's like not as much of like
um an uphill battle to get people to
like respect you
hell no I feel like
look sometimes I feel like it's good but
then sometimes I feel like they do try
to boxes in but I mean I feel like we
just artists at the end of the day [__]
our skin color brown you know like we're
yeah I'm like an artist who just happens
to be like the music is dope yeah hell
yeah but I mean I feel like we're doing
our [__] I feel like they gonna they
gotta you know I mean we going crazy
like we're going down we're doing some
like bigger numbers than some artists
who it's just we just we rapping it's
hip-hop you know 100 I feel like it
shouldn't be uh we shouldn't be our own
category I agree
I don't think we are either I don't
think we are either like I don't think
we are yeah no I think that I don't
think so but I think that like there are
still people who are like oh yeah yeah
like he's a dope Mexican rapper and it's
like well he's also just a dope rapper
he's just a rapper who's dope and oh
he's Mexican yeah yeah yeah like Cypress
Hill back in the day were just hard like
you'd be like yo that's Cypress Hill dog
the [__] are hard like yeah
it's hard you know what I'm saying oh
yeah uh who give me um like you
obviously say you were inspired by nip a
lot but like when you were growing up
like what music were you listening to
what kind of helped form your uh your
style man
um uh nip for sure
like uh let me see who else I listening
to or that
um
man I can't even think off the top of my
[__] you feel me I listen to 50 too
you got the Melodies yeah 50 was hard
who else I'm trying to think
so yeah that's that's the best those
aren't bad yeah that's all I have to
think about type [__] I was it was more
but you know I just came off the top of
my head for sure I saw you uh you got
Greedo on the album shots of Greedo he
just came through a couple months ago oh
yeah man you're doing good he got that
[__] he got the [__]
rich guy teeth now you know what I'm
saying he got them pearly whites hell
yeah you know I had to get those too
where'd you go to get your teeth uh I
went to uh right here in Studio City oh
you did it out here yeah Dr uh Trevor
Trevor you know somebody said they hop
on the plane and they'll go to like uh
Colombia Mexico pay for two five racks
and they come back looking like big ass
fake ass you know white ass teeth I'm
like oh like you don't even you didn't
even try to make them look real yeah I'd
be seeing that [__] too [__]
look like Jim Carrey The Mask yeah yeah
bro yeah uh how how obviously the new
Project's out uh how much like music do
you plan on dropping throughout the rest
of the year are you keeping the pressure
on them or like what are you doing
yeah for sure I got I got hella [__] we
got projects lined up
videos are coming a whole lot of [__]
I'm just ready to you know go I'm ready
to go crazy yeah you know have you
tapping with Bern it all who burner
burner I haven't I haven't I haven't
tapped in we gotta make that happen bro
we gotta make that [__] happen ASAP I
[__] with him too burner's a [__]
real life almost billionaire right now
yeah man he he a legend he's on a cover
of Forbes that's hard right trying to
get on the cover of force